欢迎收看最佛心幽默的财经节目
理财达人秀
我是李兆华
好,好久没有说这句话了
今天台股再创历史新高
来到了48601
但是今天的心情可能有点无味杂陈
因为到了11点、12点
台股就持续的往下杀
把涨点几乎全数吐回
留下了一个长达800点的上影线
中场只涨了80几点
所以大家会想说
是不是因为长假效应
还是应该怎么看呢
因为昨天晚上
美股的表现很厉害
而且是AI领军哦
MD Meta全数大涨哦
而他们大涨的理由
其实并不是新鲜事
而是关于AI的信心
市场的气氛全数回龙
所以今天这个长长的上影线
也许我们有一点点短暂的长假因素
但中长线来看
我们的反攻号角看来是已经
怎么样吹起来了
外销订单也在创下历史新高
台股的底气超级强
来欢迎今天的三位来宾好好讲解
第一位是AI达人蔡明翰
明翰哥
AI达人告诉大家
800点的上影线
如果一进场就早盘进去的人
可能感受不好
但他要特别讲
今天真的叫做反攻好小的响起
因为是由美股的AI科技股来全面带动
今天汉侧也正式的挂牌了
从汉侧来看整体风测
就是叫做今年好明年会更好
到底还有哪些个股符合这样的条件
我们要有信心不要被常常上影线吓到了
明汉哥等一下来告诉大家
第二位是齐全王子张宁忠
齐全王子也要来讲
熬过了所谓的九月魔咒了
剩下最后一个礼拜了
迎接光辉十月
现在外资的空单慢慢的回补
真的是一个好现象
那到底十月我们要来看哪些的股票呢
等一下也会独家帮你选
KD黄金交叉
中哥的独门绝学
再加上各股期的量增
这些都是一些好的
盘面上的热门股
现在都
有的还没有创新高
可能也要跟着创新高
一定要好好的看起来
好 第三位是我們的
雞雞醫生志圓哥好 今天你會有一個感受怎麼股票差距這麼大開盤一大堆漲停的盤中一大堆漲停打開尾盤一大堆翻黑
怎麼選
其實AI的氣氛回來
中小型股台灣是最厲害的
可是高波動
高波動的話
用基金幫你一網打進
小資族就可以輕鬆入手
這個是大家最喜歡的
等一下來教大家囉
首先有請明漢哥
今天的漲點
這個800多點後來被沒收
我覺得大家的心情很複雜
因為今天一早盤
我是覺得好開心
一口氣就創歷史新高
好沒有關係
其實這禮拜只有四個交易日
這個是一個長線的反攻號角
大家不要只看這幾天
漢測今天上市了
但你更看好的是整體封測
明年會爆發性成長
對我們先講
這個所謂的漲點被沒收
當然說台股位階相對有不同
我們先回過頭來再講
為什麼今天能夠創立新高
其實比較重要的關鍵點
就是昨天晚上
納斯達克指數創高
廢半出現大漲
所以今天市場信心就會比較好
科技類股昨天為什麼會強
兩大因素
第一個部分就是因為Muse
對 大家一直在講說
這個出來之後狀況不錯
Google或者是Apple的這個
所謂App的下載
它是免費的榜首
然後呢 外資就有提到說
未來Meta可能會有
2000億美金的這個
所謂未來資金可能會慢慢的
有機會之前投那麼多了
等於說慢慢的要開始回收了
然後呢
所以昨天股價大漲了11%
那我覺得第一件事情
對我的觀點而言
我覺得比較大的重點
先不要管下載量
我們等一下會講
再講這個城市
確實我覺得有一個
比較代表性的意義
以前就是傳統AI
你可能你要什麼出國
他只是會幫你行程排一排
現在他可以直接幫你把後面的這些
所謂的下訂或購買的東西
一次都幫你完成
這是一個很大的一個跨越
這我個人的感受
另外一個就是在講油價下跌
那重點就是之前油的卡的關
那目前來講講到有輸油管的部分
轉向亞洲市場
所以在昨天來講
一天就有七艘的大型油輪能夠運出來
所以油價就出現比較明顯的下跌
另外就是川普願意跟伊朗總統會面
我只要講一個概念
先講到這個MUSE
META的部分到底是不是真的那麼厲害我要給一個概念就是MUSE部分一週下載了73萬次然後大概10天左右
就來到這個所謂點擊率的最上緣
DeepSig等於說當時一個禮拜
其實還有260萬次
而且它真的是不到兩三天就爬到頂
那OpenAI當時是一上市馬上見頂
當然數字當時沒有那麼大
其實我只要講一個重點就是Trade
其實他上市一個禮拜就超過一億用戶
但對於這些數字
我覺得憑良心講還好而已
這為什麼能夠漲11%
可不可以解釋一下
很簡單看一下
這是今年以來的漲勢
他加上昨天的11%
今年的YTD才漲12%
所以簡單的講
今年要不是有這根
他完全沒漲
再來我們再講
昨天就是油價跟美債殖利率都有走低
可以看到昨天有走低
所以導致
那斯大克創高
可是長期而言
你會發現他們是走同向
就是股價是往上走
在線殖利率往上
所以整件事情我個人覺得
昨天能夠創高跟新聞面
一點關係的有沒有
我會覺得我們回過頭來
還是回到這個廢辦的土
回過頭來那時候七月在下跌
每天都有不同的鬼故事
我也一直跟他講
不要去聽那個
就真的是漲多拉回而已
後續自然就整理
那我之前整理的時候提到
最相對來講比較不
等於說比較大的壓力就是廢半一直在
給月線附近弱勢整理
那台股如果要獨自創高有很大的壓力
之前都提到
如果它能夠站上季線之後
整個趨勢就會反轉
那昨天來講算是首度
應該說修正以來首度站上季線
所以我覺得一定具有一定的意義
所以我覺得應該要偏向樂觀
後續來講應該就會慢慢的越走
回過頭來台股為什麼今天會有這麼長的上影線
對比一下位階就知道
我們還是一個最強的市場
要等一下廢伴
對 應該說我們中間的位階還是存在的
那我剛剛講了這一段時間我們在這裡休息
讓它多漲一點 讓我們中間的這個價差能夠收斂
絕對是正向
記得廢伴站上季線 這個真的是有意義的
所以後續來講應該說很明顯的資金有開始回籠了
所以對於無論是美股
或者是台股的部分應該都要樂觀一些對於META讓這個代理人AI這件事情是有意義的市場正向看待氣氛回來費半戰上季線這些都有意義那我們今天台股的上一線
除了要等人家之外
可能因為長假
也有人說今天大家會賣股變現
好 明漢怎麼看
我覺得過往紀錄
在最後幾天亮縮
本來就是合理的現象
但絕對不代表會跌
那只是說今天就是上
因為大漲又爆量
所以相對而言
會有一些人想要在節前
先拿一點回來
我覺得是合理
可是你看一下
就是這三年有AI以來
中秋節過後台股表現
其實憑良心講
他也是往上走
所以你真的要在節前
就獲利了解
我剛剛講了
如果你今天持股很高
我覺得沒有問題
但是如果你持股也不是很高
你現在要考慮的
剛剛提到過往經驗
在節後他是漲的
然後現在等了那麼久
費半終於站上季線
終於來了
對 然後這個時候你突然要減碼
你應該考 如果你低持股
應該考量怎麼加碼
我覺得才是對的
那至於如果持股比較高的
節錢拿一點回來
我覺得合理
而且可以預期再來的兩天
成交量能可能會持續縮減
我覺得是合理
除非這兩天的美股有大波動
如果沒有 台股就應該量縮
然後震盪的幅度會比美股小
我覺得才是合理
一樣問題就是這幾天
我們的漲勢會不如美股
或者是他們下跌
我們跌幅也會比美股小一點
我覺得才是合理
除了中秋節後會正向之外
即將進入十月這第四季
我相信這大家知道的應該也很多
所以我個人覺得真的
在廢半站上這個季線之後
第四季的波段行情
我覺得機率是高的
雖然說今年已經漲很多了
可是整個架構來講
還是會維持多頭
還是一樣就是維持高持股
當然先決條件
你的資金要盡量往AI靠攏
從今天的盤勢還是可以看得到
應該說第二季強勢的時候
或者是這一段現在開始轉強的看到
資金就是一直往AI所謂的移動
反而不是AI的族群
其實即使今天上半場
指數大漲的時候
也不見得能夠漲到你的股票
所以剛剛提到資金往AI靠攏
維持高持股
所以我還是建議要
這個四度的這個報股過節
我還是覺得不用太擔心
所謂的中秋節的問題
好 這次的明翰跟前面幾次
有點不一樣的是
有時候長得比較多
因為今天創歷史新高
都會提醒大家
台股在世界第一強這個是有點危險的
可是今天的狀況有點不一樣
因為費半納指都上來了
反而是覺得要迎接第四季的好光景
是 台積電很特別
昨天台積電的ADR是收幾乎最高
可是我們今天卻是收最低
你覺得這其實也是好現象
對 我也覺得是好現象
之前我們來節目也給大家看到這個
所謂的台積電的所謂的溢價的狀況
就是這兩三個月以來不斷的下跌
那為什麼就是台股太強
一直在歷史新高附近震盪
完全跌不下去
但是台積電ADR有一個比較明顯的修正
現在距離高點還有接近10%左右
所以希望現在要看到絕對不是台股
趕快創高
現在要的是ADR趕快補漲
所以目前的角度ADR能夠大漲
那台積電沒有上去
我覺得是好現象
我希望的是
ADR不要被這根所壓抑
通常他會看到台股今天開高走低
今天晚上ADR就容易修正
我是希望不要修正 繼續漲
然後台股一直都不要漲
讓這個議價差能夠拉開
對台股都是正向的
另外今天可以看到
聯發科的部分來講
確實還是相對強勢
也在創歷史新高
對 它很特別的
就是這些強勢族群有一個特色
就是2027年的EPS
都是大幅成長的
雖然聯發科今年的EPS沒有動
但是市場的均值都認為
明年獲利會翻倍
所以股價的一個部分自然強勢
創意的部分就是非常不可思議的公司
就是今年獲利成長八成
明年還可以成長130%
所以股價的部分自然有機會不斷走高
我覺得這個也都是數字會說話
另外星星的部分也算是表現很好
今年是因為基期低
所以EPS成長是三倍以上
明年還是有超過八成
我覺得都沒問題
之前因為這個所謂的
看到減掉的一個部分導致拉回
這幾天休息一段時間沒有太大動靜
自然還是會反應基本面而轉強
今天宰版三雄都很兇
台積電據說魏哲嘉在前兩天
遇到蔡立行跟他說
我們的股價會趕上聯發科
希望然後網友就說要向上趕上
不要聯發科向下趕上
應該不會 因為兩個趨勢
因為剛剛提到兩個明年的趨勢
都還在往上
當然我憑良心講
我覺得他要趕上聯發科是不太可能
因為股本各樣條件另外就告訴大家確實撼測要掛牌狂飆先講一件事情最近因為他掛牌所以導致這些所謂的我們看到這些探針
對探針卡感覺都蠻慘的
我跟大家講暫時的而已
所有看到探針卡利空耳朵遮起來
千萬不要聽
真的基本面很好
純粹因為漢測的資金效應而已
持有者要一點耐心
他們的營收真的都很強
獲利也都很好
只是這個資金來講
至今來講就轉向
休息一段時間的這個封測屬群
那只是外資的報告
這要告訴大家說
為什麼現在的封測很好
是因為先進封裝的需求很強
那從這個是
所謂藍色是26 黃色是27年
你可以看到
26 27都還在快速成長當中
從輝達到博通超微
連發科在這裡
另外還有Marvel之外看到創意
所以你可以看到這些被點名的個股
他們需要大量的所謂的
我們剛剛講的先進封裝
代表他業績面非常強勁
那這些AI的先進封裝
到底誰提供的
這個是台積電是藍色的
黃色的就是非台積電
就是我們等一下會講的
這個晶圓電 日月光
另外Intel的部分也有提供
未來的部分還會有台積電的
Corpus的部分也會加入陣營
所以看起來
重點就是AI的需求
從探真卡一直到
後段的這些封裝的部分來講
都是正向的
所以這幾天持有這些探針卡的
我拉回真的不要害怕
純粹是資金的效應
真的 我只能講基本面很好
那這些個股來講
我們就幫大家挑選一些封測的個股
那結論就是AI關聯度比較高的
就是有辦法跨入先進封裝的
還是日月光跟晶圓店
相對來講算是兩檔比較標準的個股
那以日月光來講
今年獲利增長快一倍
然後明年還有辦法增長五成
要跟大家概念
看到今年EPS成長96%
這是現在
年初的時候大概只有預估接近四成
所以代表他的獲利
一直以來都是優位預期不斷上修
所以不要擔心說
為什麼這裡96明年只剩五成
這未來都還有可能持續調整
最起碼他們的趨勢都還在
晶圓店也有一個比較特別要告訴大家
他今年獲利看起來沒成長
去年他有一個一次性的業外
所以導致基期很高
其實他本業獲利
或者是你看到他的營收成長其實是很強是沒有問題的所以明年預估還有接近六成的EPS成長所以這兩檔我還是覺得比較中心的核心思想
另外聯軍的部分也可以留意
因為它是所謂的光通訊的封測
所以它比較特別
那我只要講個重點就是
它的獲利成長也非常優秀
營收表現也不差
可是它有個缺點
就是它的透明度相對比較低一點
我是講從法人的角度
所以他的報告少
然後訊息相對少
所以風險稍微偏高一點點
另外中高階半導體
雖然沒有到直接的整個
所謂的跟AI有直接相關
但還是有一些間接性
獲利也不錯
所以應該說如果你想要
買便宜一點的
等於說本益比相對比較低的個股
對 可以從這個角度出發
最後的部分就記憶體的部分
記憶體封測其實他們的獲利不錯
所以本益比也都不高
但是這個記憶體封測
可能他的走勢就跟記憶體族群
會有比較直接相關
他就不見得會跟著封測族群
所以可能投資人來講
要稍微拿捏一下
你自己比較喜歡的一個方向
新學系格都是非常好的公司
而且多少都有跟CPU也要切近
預算還有擅出型封裝
其實大家都多題材去發展
是 只是說
對 現在大家因為AI
現在已經第三年了
所以大家也都不斷耕耘
只是說比例的問題
現在相對而言
還是這兩家的比例相對比較高
簡單而言從去年底
開始台積電吃不下來
必須得流到外面之後
就是以這兩家吃到的比例相對比較高
慢慢的當然會往下延伸
只是這速度的問題
所以就目前角度
我還是覺得投資的方向來講
日月光晶圓電相對來講
就是獲利比較穩健的個股
應該是比較不同的說
或者是反過頭來
如果你今天想買
這些所謂有價值的個股
你應該要選擇不是封測熱的時候
就平常冷沒人要的時候
你可以減
這個時間點現在市場上資金進來
再轉強 你硬要切入
你就盡量選擇這種
相對比較穩健的個股
也許漲多到這邊可能會拉回
但是後續而言
大型個股明明比較不會害怕
你才能夠持續加碼
好 這個日月光 晶圓電
絕對是可以統包的
日月光是全世界第一大的封測股
金元電也算是前幾大的風色股
所以這邊的話
先選龍頭這段時間
就比較不會FOMO了沒錯這邊非常謝謝明翰好 真的要謝謝明翰大家還有印象嗎也不過就是上個禮拜二台股的量縮起來我們都說
這叫CPI公佈前
聯準會開會前的
致息量
那個時候真的很需要
大家對台灣AI發展的信心
所以那天送信心
那今天果然我們創下了歷史新高
又留下了一個上限
還是需要信心
看一下吧
我們的底氣真的很強
今年好
明年繼續高速成長喔
那當然因為今天創高壓回的關係
如果要切入的話以封測來說
這絕對是明年更好的產業
不妨先以龍頭股為您的首選
而其他的一定要切記囉
每一次告訴大家
在低迷的時候
在量縮的時候
就是最好的切入點
這個在之後依舊是很受用的
好廣告回來
我們的中哥要上場的外銷訂單
今天下午公佈了
破千億美元再創歷史新高
這麼強的底氣
我們來選股
中哥的KD黄金交叉
各股其量增
就是人气的所在
刚刚特别有提到一件事情
台股不能独自美丽
我们在这边是要等美股跟上
而美股大有表现
当然也因为这个礼拜
还有所谓的川习会
给了美股也蛮多的希望
但是这边就要来请教中哥了
我们的外交订单
下午出炉了
再说历史新高
外资的空单其实有慢慢的回补
你觉得是好现象
所以10月是看好的
你今天帮我们锁定Q4高胜率
以及你的黄金交叉量增固
对 其实这个礼拜除了这个廉价之外
我觉得这个特殊的经济事件并没有太多
其实上个礼拜已经过
上个礼拜我觉得算是魔王州
魔王州
对 就是BOJ还有这个四五日
还有这个FED升息
那其实对这个美股跟台股
都没有造成太大杀伤力
那我们来看这个礼拜可能会遇到什么事情
一樣就是9.24
這一天是禮拜四
川席會 黃仁勳 庫克 奧特曼
馬斯克跟皮查
皮查理大家可能比較熟悉
Alphabet 就是Google的老闆
所以帶了這麼大的科技巨頭陣仗去那邊
當然有三大議題
第一個 關稅是否能夠休戰
11月10號原本是要到期
然後AI晶片跟稀土
稀土掌握在中國
AI晶片主要當然就是美國在控制
是否能夠銷進去
所以我覺得兩方牽制之下
這一次大概就過個場
我覺得大概就一世性了
就大概就是和樂融融
那對大盤其實不太會有殺傷力
但我覺得往上可能也沒有
就是大概就是大家聽一個川習會
一個名詞這樣子
好 不過這兩天
美股的AI股是復活
然後川普也有特別提到
有AI的部隊
要認命AI的沙皇
然後說會前會兩邊
對AI的看法也談得很好
我覺得多少氣氛上有點
氣氛是不錯
但其實大家對川普的言論
我覺得也沒有什麼太大的感覺
是
包括美股對美國的經濟數據
也沒有太大的感覺
好 我們先來看一下台灣實質面
我們剛才左邊都在講口水
又被人家講真的東西
今天下午公布的8月的外銷訂單
1030億美金
其實上個月只有多少
上個月大概應該是不到1000億
900多 對 900多
所以不論是月增
MON或是年增 YOY
都是相當的強勢
但我們知道基本面好
可能股市半年前就開始反映了
所以2026 1月1號到現在
其實股市還是持續往上
當然7月遇到一個下彎
我想很多人都知道
重挫就是要買
當然現在看起來都對
但是7月你不一定敢買
這就是這個人性
所以股市一直在考驗人性
我們從這個既然基本面好
那你就等
假設大家都說中秋變盤對不對
如果下禮拜一真的重挫
一開盤跌2% 3%
當然你還是站在買方比較對
我覺得應該不會變盤
雖然很多人喜歡談這個議題
好 我們來看這個裡面當中
誰變化最多
當然就是最好
資訊通信100%
電子產品83%
這兩個獨佔凹頭
這跟什麼有關
當然還是跟AI 半導體
相關伺服器 晶片等等
都在這個範圍當中
我們反而是要特別留意一下
像2月份這邊有凹下來
主要還是跟應該過年是有關係
如果你看到後續從這個
第四季以後
90 11 12
如果有看到這個往下的趨勢
你才可能假設賺太多的股票
可能可以稍微逢高拔檔
否則大家都不太需要去管它
當然像基本金屬機械這種傳統產業的
也算是還不錯的年增率喔
所以才能一起創下千億元的外銷訂單
是 所以整體來說都是
等於從AI相關有外溢到
例如說一些電力設備其實都還不錯
好 那基本面好
我們再來看一下這個技術面跟籌碼
台紙其實這一波在
我上次來應該是兩週前
其實盤是不好的 它是往下走
我們看到當時的閃戶也都在做多
所以我們那時候是說可能要等一下 我說是盤整好 我們看最近最近三四天第一個散戶的空單開始翻空了散戶空單最好就是能夠複製
像今年4月份
我們看到這一串對不對
散戶支付在做空
大盤大漲
所以現在也又來了
在中秋節前後散戶翻空
雖然說今天的空單是回補
因為它停損
它昨天其實有2萬口
今天剩下4500口
因為今天一開 開很高
他可能有點害怕到 嘎到
所以他這邊開始慢慢的把空單回補
這個對大盤有點扣分
但是我們從這個架構來看
他還是空單
所以一樣是對多方是有利的
再來我們看這個外資
外資從這一波的低點這個位置
你看他的這個空單是緩緩的補上去
很緩
他緩到幾乎是讓你看不出來
一千口一千口這樣做
但是你看後續
這一波上來
其實外資是現貨買很多
要買了4000億以上
所以代表現貨是比較重要的
期貨一直都是在做避險
如果期貨開始回補空單
就會有軋空
軋空力道的話
大盤你說要供這個高點
這個是台子期
供它我覺得第四季
輕鬆就可以達到 對
今天是現貨過
其實台子期還沒有過前面的高點
這邊有到49000多點
對 所以現在現貨過 期貨沒過
如果你看這個價格發現的功能的話
代表大家還是稍微保守
就是連價錢
他覺得暫時沒有那麼快
能夠滾過去
所以這是籌碼面
再來我們看資金
這個指標一樣
我們上次來講的時候是綠色
這個我們看美國
納斯達克跟道琼的強弱勢
我們上次來應該是9月的時候
那是綠色對不對
綠色所以大盤是
大概就是盤整
而且整個8月都是綠色
對 如果是綠色的話
代表錢是放在防禦型的道琼
我們看在昨天
禮拜一翻了紅色
迎接鐘哥的到來
所以納斯達克
不敢說他迎接我
納斯達克開始大漲
那我們就要留意一下
美國的錢現在流到科技股
但是台灣還沒有 要留意一下
台灣的指標日線還是綠色
小時線兩個市場都已經翻紅
但是如果看日線的話
台灣還沒有 可能要再等幾天
萬萬沒想到今天是創高
卻還沒有
對
這是資金
好 如果這個錢還沒有回到這邊
我們來看我們最喜歡看的外資投信投信的買盤對 就是營收好的我們抓40%然後投信最近一個月持股超過150檔兩個條件很嚴格
剩下6檔
對
就全台灣剩下6檔
6檔喔
他這邊寫8檔
還想投讀2檔
但是6檔
對 那可能小編自己有2檔
要放進去
沒有 我們就看6檔
好 我們看這6支股票
是
那我教大家一個簡單的方式
我們看那個DMI指標
好 DMI
我們說要再交一次
很多觀眾留言說
還真的忘記了
DMI它就是
你會看到紅色線跟綠色線
如果紅線在上面你就做多
然後搭配一條10天均線
如果同時站上的話
它就是最好的買點
例如說我們看創意好了
我們看這3443的創意對不對
好 你往前看
DMI在哪邊黃金交叉
這邊嗎
是不是在這個地方
好 那有沒有在
10天均線上面
也有嘛
所以那邊你就
都很適合去買進它
在這個這一塊
因為它這邊已經剛好是黃金交叉了
對
當然這個趨勢走出來
它就會一路一直擴散上去
它是強勢
對 我們比較害怕什麼
害怕就是兩條線一直在糾纏
像這一塊
糾纏
對 它就是紅線跟藍線一直在穿來穿去
那就是多空
其實沒有什麼趨勢
就是這一大段
你就很容易受傷
然後就會開始去咒罵張林中
說你講這個根本就不準
對 因為沒有趨勢就是會這樣
我們要找這種黃金交叉的好不好
黃金交叉現在看起來超級準耶
這邊 這邊都是一些起漲點
對 所以這六檔裡面
現在看起來是四毫兩壞
其實沒有全面的翻多
這跟以前我們在大多頭看到的
這個架構也不太一樣
這樣可以留意一下
比較差的話
我們看藍色還在上面的話
大概就是
台光電
對 台光電 台光電還是藍色在上面
然後旺系現在藍色剛穿上了
對 就這兩檔看起來比較弱勢
其他這四檔看起來
其實狀況都還不錯
好 不過剛剛明亥有把旺系打氣
探針系列
明年真的很好啦
是 好
除了那六檔之外
我們來看一下傳統Q4
我們有做過一個研究
如果你10月買股票放到3月
過去25年
平均的漲幅是8.5%
25年
另外一個半年
就是你4月買股票
然後到9月賣股票
然後這個報酬率大概是0.82所以兩個差了滿多的嘛聰明如你 你要選哪一種趕快買 放到明年3月對 所以就是10月初買股票大概3月底賣是最好的
好 除了這個半年半年來區隔之外
我們來看Q4的特性
剛才這個明翰老師有講過
上漲機率66到80
漲幅3.7到4.9
所以第四季都不太適合去賣股票
當然你可以聚焦一些電子供應鏈
AI相關等等
好 我們也特別的找了一下
Q4勝率比較高的古期的標的
古期 怎麼找呢
對 大概有這些了
台積電這個我想大家也很清楚
應該每個人都有
台積電跟0050
對 這個是一對的
然後像這個漢堂 中信金
聯發科跟廣達
這些也都可以參考一下
這些是歷史上Q4上漲機率非常高的
非常高的 對
除了這個左邊這一塊就是
就是我們看那個勝率之外
右邊就是看KD
KD黃金交差不容易發生
但只要發生 又配上行情大的話
其實都還滿有機會的
一樣 這三個條件我們常常在講
我想大家應該都會背了
好 請您再講一次
對 好 我們講那個三個條件
第一個 股期的量要有
要不就500口 1000口 2000口
這幾個條件再選
這第一個就是你的量要出來
第二個 股價超過10天均
而且均線正在向上
斜率往上就是多方股票
如果是往下的話
最好不要去買進它
第三個是KD黃金交叉
交叉不容易
這個大概一天只能出現一次
所以三個同時符合
最近一 兩天其實只有這幾檔複合
全台股只有這四檔出列了
而且滿多是熱門的
友達這兩天超熱
你用這個方式
不論它在哪一天突然要爆發的時候
它一定會被你抓到
它就像是你在守株待兔
在樹洞外面等
它要跑出來
你就看到它跑出來
我們舉個例子
連發給我想它已經創高了
就這個DMI的角度來看其實
我們是不是錯過它了
已經錯過一段時間
大概在這個位置
大概就是8月底 9月初的時候
我們錯過它怎麼辦
因為它這邊黃金交叉
如果我們不想要追高
那也沒關係
我們就去等
等它稍微靠近時間均線一下
正常應該還是會有機會
可以稍微等到
然後這是聯發科的一個狀況
這很準耶 因為這一段都在盤整
然後這一段就在那邊糾結
對 那中信金也是一樣
其實最好的買點在這個位置
也是9月初
那對過來看就是在這邊
是
所以現在看起來好像也過了
現在有點靠近了
這個其實中訊金的機會
慢慢地出現
好 大家學起來
怎樣回檔的時候再度出現
這個紅線往上的時候
就可以來運用了
對 或是下次遇到股災
對啊 股災的時候一定是
一定是藍色會在上面
像這樣 像你看漢堂
漢堂你看這邊是不是藍色在上面
一直到最近 有沒有
那你看這一段
你買這個焊塘會不會很不太舒服
照理說是不舒服
你看現在有點起來了
機器比較低的狀況
其實可以去參考它
相對可能有機會
再來你看這個廣達
廣達也是一樣
我覺得它也算是比較溫吞一點
你看從這邊到這邊
都是屬於一個糾結
但現在紅色在上面
所以這個也可以去留意一下
可是因為它這段時間一直交錯
是不是要等它稍微拉大一點
你可以看它跟這個均線
如果說這個突然衝上去
像最近的這個封測就有這種味道
沖上去的話
你去追低跟我覺得都還來得及
好
除了這個之外
我們來看剛才說那個KD
我們說在那個速動外面等對不對
像你看聯電
聯電在這一天
它就衝出來就被抓到了
沒錯
KD51下黃金交叉
而且它是第一檔黃金交叉
對 它在8月25號去
我們就發現聯電可能會發動
這邊大概到現在是28%
景碩大概是在
一樣是8月初
對 8月3號這邊
第一檔黃金交叉
當然我們的交叉沒有在管基期
我們只管交叉
但是不管怎樣
你都會把它找出來
這是過去
現在比較符合的話
像友達
友達在昨天是黃金交叉
他是偏高檔的
他在50以上
你看今天的開盤
如果你追的話
其實肉比較少一些
因為紅棒看起來相對比較少一點
當然你看另外一個是
2605星星的期貨
好 展裝
對 昨天交叉 今天是黑棒
所以你可以留意一下
這個機會可能就會來了
對 再來最後一檔是這個聯帽
同國基反 前兩天遇難的
對 這個黑棒就是
它那個鬼故事發生的時候
其實鬼故事之後慢慢的往上走
KD在這邊它有一點黃金交叉
所以你用這個方式
不論它是漲多壓回
或是從第一檔漲上去
其實你都可以去找到
不過廉價的
中哥會用這個台子期避險嗎
當然你要台詞其實避險的成本比較高你要的話可以學雲翔哥你就買一些簡單PUT是不是買一些便宜的PUT它是比較適合的好 現在恐怕沒有太便宜的PUT
可以買
對 因為現在全力金比較多一點
對...
非常謝謝鍾哥
好 鍾哥說
有時候新聞事件真的就是
檯面上大家討論的
但是真金白銀的籌碼表態
這個很重要
所以他常常用指標
幫我們來篩選股票
尤其是個股期的量增
代表市场上人气来咯
而一些指标能够做黄金交叉
不管是高档或低档的KD
往上黄金交叉
事实上都有机会延伸出
一个波段的行情
这边帮大家选了很多盘面上的热门股
以及刚刚交叉的好股票
提供给您做选股参考咯
好 广告回来
志源哥要上场了
刚讲了那么多
今天看到盘面上
一早百花齐放
盘中又纷纷落马了
到底该怎么办
交给专业的经理人
大家知道今年的中小型基金
多会涨吗
等一下志源哥来告诉您
昨天晚上美股其实很热闹
那只创高了
费半大涨4个百分点以上
我们看到Meta Intel AMD
各个去往上急喷
那当然这样的行情
很诱人在台股的话
一定是中小型股
才会有这样的一个活泼度
不过这边就要请教志源哥了
因为今天创高
虽然中小型股
我们都知道更飙
可是你看刚刚像敏翰也讲了
如果你现在才要介入
可能你买大型全资股
你压力没那么大
但是又很羡慕中小型股在飙
其实用基金
更能达到这样的目的
对 因为现在盘面的节奏
真的变化得非常的快
有时候我们想要去抓
这个盘面的节奏
还是真的不是那么容易
那当然现在
当我们台股还在纠结说
中秋变盘的时候
美股给了方向
那当然昨天的一个盘面
以前被称之为阿斗的Intel
现在不能叫人家阿斗
你看这个现行多强
跳空
那当然来讲有一个利多
其实这一段时间
我觉得都有利多
包括美国政府的一个介入也好
现在来讲的话
他现在还要跟我们的友达
冲进所谓的先进封装
所以呢
过去被认为是大牛的友达
现在也不得了
今天也是大早
而且是連續兩天都大漲的一個情況
另外一檔是AMD的一個部分的話也是這樣的一個狀況就是說它的一個今年以来的投资报酬率非常的高并回答还多很多很多每次有180%
那昨天的股价
也是在创新高
所以你看
其实在美国的一个
盘面上面来讲
都有一个
很不一样的一个状况
那其实呢
台股也是这个样子
所以我们看到
就是说
当然今天最亮眼的部分
就是在创意身上
那创意当然
我觉得它有几个利多
基本面的部分
當然有台積電的
這個產能的一個支援
另外來講
外資Alethia它預估說
創意未來三年的一個獲利
會增加八倍
那載板的部分
之前新興這樣的一個利空
其實沒有把載板的部分
給打下來
南電其實就在千元的附近
進行震盪
今天載板三雄也是都非常的強
我們以南電作為例子來講的話
感覺上來講
好像都有在供的这种意味在
那当然为什么呢
台湾这些中小型股
为什么可以特别的飙
比台积电这些
可能大型的全市股
都还来得飙
我觉得最主要还是来自于
我们基本面的底气非常的好
那当然我们讲到
这个投资价值的话
一般都会先看
本益比的一个部分
那我们看我们台股的本益比
我觉得呢
真的是还有在上锈的空间
我们算便宜的市场
对 真的好便宜
便宜的市场
以這個深藍色的未來12個月的
前瞻本益比來講的話
就算是在最高點7月份的時候
6月底7月份的時候
也不過才20多倍
那現在呢
大概在19倍上下
那如果你是以未來24個月
就未來兩年的前瞻本益比來看的話
它更只有多少
不到15倍
你可能會覺得說
為什麼未來兩年反而更低
對啊 我們越漲越便宜
對 就是因為我們獲利
變得又更好了
所以右边这张你可以看到
就是说台湾上市柜的
这个EPS的成长的一个水位来讲
红色的部分是2027年
你看它成长的这个抖度
非常的高
那相较于2025年
比较平缓的一个状况来讲的话
这些增加很多
所以预估在今年
它的这个年增长率的部分
就大概四成以上
那明年更高
到五成以上
所以你换算下来的话
可能真的是越涨
反而是越便宜的一個狀況
我們的評價超合理
對 那台股為什麼這麼強
我告訴大家
因為快要第三季了我剛好也做一個所謂的一個統計的部分台股今年的漲幅差不多是60%很強對不對對
告訴大家這個漲幅剛好跟廢半
還有韓國的部分平起平坐
那為什麼可以這麼強
就是因為我們在基本面的部分
真的是非常的強
那過去可能我們都會講說
我們種在所謂的AI半導體
但現在是一個全面的擴散
擴散到什麼
AI的基建 五層蛋糕
黃人群獎的
包括我們有最完整的
AI的一個供應鏈
所以我們在社會的族群的部分
譬如說像GPU的算力增加的話
會好到什麼
PCB跟CCL
那功耗大幅的成長的話
就會好到所謂的
電源供應的一個部分
那AI的晶片設計越來越複雜
所以半導體測試的部分
也是非常非常的強
那其他部分包括像ABF載板
還有已經漲過好幾輪的記憶體
這些都是非常強的一個族群
那这边呢
再比较细的跟大家讲一下
就是AI带动的层面呢
对我们台股来讲是非常的多
从上游的部分你可以看到
包括像IC设计的部分
还有包括刚刚明昊也提到的
半导体测试的
还有我们刚刚讲记忆体的部分
那更好的部分呢
其实在这些所谓的关键零组件上面
因为关键零组件呢
它基本上来讲
它获利的一个成长的幅度又更高
所以像最近盘面的一个主流
雖然變化得很快
但是都集中在這些族群上面
包括什麼 散熱
散熱 今天也是高麗雙紅都漲停
對 窄板的部分
三雄都漲停
前一波的光
雖然今天光沒有什麼表現
但是光其實都還一直都滿亮的
電源供應器的部分
其實在從去年延伸到現在
也都沒有太大的一個改變
其他的部分
我們如果以光收發模組來看的話
其實高盛之前就有出一個報告
是不斷地看好
今年跟明年
因為包括800G跟1.6T的
收發模組的部分
都是會不斷的一個成長
雖然這個FCC有一個雜音
但是其實好像也沒有發生
太大的一個改變
講這個CCL可能因為CPU普及
就用不到那麼高規格
但幾天內就已經沒有人在聊了
好 那接下來可能你會講到就是說
如果我要捕捉剛剛講的那些個股
你會發現到就是盤面的節奏
並不是容易那麼掌握
而且有些大部分很貴
對
所以我覺得我們為什麼一直強調
就是推薦大家就是說
你比較省心的方式
其實是可以用基金或ETF的方式
來進行布置
〔此段辨識失敗，約 40:00 起〕